alright
[Music]
hello how's hello sali jaramillo
with today's top headlines clark
county school district is
now recommending that
students be in
full-time distance learning for the
upcoming school year this is a change to
the approved school plan  at the beginning of the
month that gave parents the option
to send their children two days to the
classroom and three days to stay at home,
however the change to be
totally online must be approved by
the state school board
for another  part the
nevada treasury department is accepting
new applications for a
rental assistance program
the state's rent moratorium for people
who lost their jobs and must pay their
rent begins on september 1
this program has 60 million
dollars  from
federal government kers aid to qualify
review the requirements on our page
news now diagonal en  spanish
clinical trials for a
covenant vaccine and will soon be taking place
in clark county the company and ivy
queen x files is looking for
healthy people who want to participate in
this study you must be over 18 and
have never tested positive for the virus
if you  interested you should contact the
investigative team for details visit
disney.com now with their
weather forecast a sunny and hot day is expected
the maximum will be in the 107
degrees and the small
chances of rain will continue winds and
lightning this week have a good
day  I am salt and jaramillo and this was
unusual in Spanish
[Music]